let me start with the backdrop and so
nowadays there is a vast amount of
mathematical material and knowledge out
there in the sights exemplify such as
the archive and a lot of it has not been
systematized and on the other hand you
have this issue of your mathematician
whether you're just a grad student or
seasoned mathematician the way you get
inducted into a field is by either
talking to your advisor or a colleague
about something and they will give you a
few seminal papers with a few theorems
that you need to get started on and that
process can often be tedious and slow
and what we want to do here one of the
goals is to facilitate that so that you
are able to retrieve the theorem and
deep dig into that knowledge base as
fast as you can and this easily as you
can so and to harness that vast amount
of knowledge out there of course the
first step is to try to understand it
and what does it mean to understand a
mathematical body of work you first want
to understand the statements the
theorems and to understand it is to try
to parse it first and that's what we
started with so let's first try some
parsing oh let's see it looks a lot
better great so there are a myriad of
challenges here so first of all you want
to figure out a good way to represent
your theorem your statement and you want
to be specific enough to fully express
the diversity and the semantic meaning
of a theorem because there's so many of
them kinds of statements in math yeah
you want it to be universal enough such
that your expressions going to be
uniform and encompass all of them or as
many as possible and luckily we can take
advantage of the full symbolic
capability
of the watermen language and you will
see this language we designed in just a
moment and so another challenge is to
properly interpret your theorem
semantically and to just get a taste of
this problem in say English let's say
you want the statement they ate the
pizza with anchovies so this is how you
would naturally interpret it most of the
time however if you just look at it
grammatically you could very well think
that it could mean something like this
right who said that you ate the pizza
the anchovies with the pizza rather than
you eating it with anchovies so and
these problems of course can mean just
give vastly different parses and we want
to be very careful when the way
interpret and try to parse the mass and
so this is where also you need some
domain knowledge in mathematics to be
able to do the parsing because we
actually analyzed a lot of the sentence
structures and possible parses to really
see well what is the most probable parts
and sometimes they might be different
from how someone would say in English
right so and the analogous statement
would be for example are the reals is an
extension of Q the rationals in C the
complexes and in this case in C probably
a human would think with a qualified R
instead of Q so and so another challenge
is to come up with a set of mathematical
concepts so there are a set of terms and
notions that are being used in the
literature but there isn't actually a
collection of words that describe these
different kinds of concepts so we did a
vast amount of frequency analysis based
on say frequency of a particular term or
concept occurring in a mathematical text
versus a general English text
in English or well in just say
newspapers and based on these frequency
analysis we were able to create a set of
terms that describe concepts that are
very likely to be just mass concepts and
so what that's what we use to produce a
corpus of terms that are not just
singleton words but also by grants and
three grams and so forth and we also
want to incorporate a set of tolerance
and by that we mean what if we didn't
happen to make this concept in our
vocabulary and someone introduces a new
concept what do we do so we want to be
able to make the system extensible and
for it to encompass new terms as well so
I'll show some of this and there's no
point in me talking about it okay let me
not give up by the way okay so let's
begin there's a very simple example a
field is a ring so this is the fact and
so we want to parse this and the
structure that we created for this one
as you can see is it has a head of
sentence and then this is a statement
and this has a carnality a so in Mass
this is actually quite important whether
you say a or a Mike in for uniqueness
and so forth and so this is objects this
concept with type field and this has
property is ring and so this is the
structure that we create it and to
visualize this this is the way that you
can see the tree is being built and so
and here you have this tree denoting
this math object just for more easier
visualization and this apple denoting a
particular property and in the sisk in
this case is ring is a property of the
concept field and we designed it such
that there are several different kinds
of
or sentence structures for example for
all and there exists essentially these
different structures and for this one
this is the parse and then we have it
can recognize the existence statement
and here you have the universal covering
which is a two gram it's a concept in
our corpus that was created based on the
frequency analysis we did earlier and
with the carnality so that's how we
represent this
so let's now have some fun by gradually
building up a tree and just see how the
parser creates a full tree so let's
start with the simplest structure
suppose I just want so the sequence is a
resolution and so this is what the
parcel bigger first come up with and you
can see this is pretty similar to what
we just saw you have a statement and you
have this path properties and you have
this object with some qualifiers and
then the property it has and now let's
try to make this more extensible so now
let's say admissible now you can see
that the qualifier gets popped in and if
I say suppose that now this has a
hypothesis head attached to it so it's
recognizing that it's in psychosis and
say of links and so here you can see
that the qualifiers has changed and you
have this resolution of links N and so
next say of the projection p 0 so this
is one tricky part that we saw earlier
with the anchovies example in that the
off the projection could very well mean
projection of links or projection of
resolution but in this case it's much
more likely that this is going to be
modifying the resolution rather than the
links
whereas if you supposedly change this
and say where n is greater than 1 so
here then n is greater than 1 is going
to be modifying links so there are some
subtleties that we do how to take into
account and build that into the parser
yeah so this is a finish tree and there
are also other kinds of structures such
as the ones with both hypothesis and
statements and so forth right so this is
more example right so earlier I did say
that our parser is supposed to be fault
tolerant and let's try something that's
perhaps more fun and I totally did not
come up with this before except I did
say grow these words are not in my
vocabulary
in California these are true for us I
know sorry then catalyze it so you can
see here that this did correctly pick up
the correct structure and so the parser
has some boots dropping built in based
on certain words it does know and what
possible things parses could result
right and of course you can change it
and it will be similarly compatible so
great so yeah ok suppose that not the
chance of publicly embarrass myself in
public oh it did pick up the hypothesis
yeah so they should yes anything else oh
yes
right right so in this case right it's a
list in this case right and in
particular as you see here or don't have
boolean and and that's actually exactly
the reason why I use lowercase e rather
uppercase e right so that Mathematica
the Wolfram language will now think of
it as the logical conjunction but yeah
that's absolutely right great we can
have some more fun with that later if
you like and just a few more words on
the implementation so this is a bottom
up parser that I realize some
context-free grammars and we produce a
set of competing parses to and then rank
them and the why you see is the highest
ranked one and the ranking is actually
quite tricky because you want to make
sure to take into account things like we
discussed earlier about how prepositions
are associated entities and so forth
right okay so and then these points we
discussed earlier right great so now
let's talk about how we might be using
the parse so now that we have a chance
to get to know a theorem let's see how
we can harness the structure that we
created from the theorem using the parse
so a search would of course be very
useful for various things so maybe I
should just cut to the chase in the
interest of time and show you some
examples rather than bringing you this
through the bullet points and then I
should go through the same thing at exit
force
okay so this is so we build that into an
system where you can you have this web
interface and access and search the
database that we created so the database
here is papers that we excrete from
archive so there are over a million
papers all total and all of them about
300,000 mathematical physics and math
papers from which we extracted theorems
from and there was a pretty elaborate
process of extraction and latex
processing and so forth and so the goal
of this is not so much of a general
search engine simply because we are
basing our database from say archive
which are the latest cutting-edge
technology and wealth rather mass
research and so you have here rather
very specialized and esoteric kind of
theorems but it is good if you have
specific search terms and you want to
find the latest results on a particular
concept so for example you're not going
to find much on say group because group
is a very general concept that people
have known for hundreds of years but
there might be more on say finite simple
group and so this interface here are
going to be some results here containing
this and you will note that for some of
these we have two parts in our result
one is the actual theorem itself that we
extracted from of the various papers and
then the contextual aspect meaning many
papers that we see are actually just
snippets containing symbols that were
defined elsewhere in the text and of
course it's not useful for you to just
look at the symbols without knowing the
context so we actually went and
extracted these possible definitions of
concepts and symbols that occur
elsewhere earlier in the paper and to
display it for you and suppose you want
to actually look at a paper you can go
right away to the archive
wink and dig on a further so okay so
without further ado so we can so here
earlier so one distinguishing feature
from of this particular search versus a
the more Channel Google Scholar or
Wikipedia or Microsoft academic search
is we look specifically in a particular
theorem
instead of throughout the text and we
semantically parse it so that we try to
get a result
that's faithfully semantically faithful
as possible to the input and so for
example let's try something like closure
of a subgroup of abelian variety and so
you know abelian varieties are naturally
their varieties equipped with a group
structure and okay so I'm on VPN so it
seems a lot slower than what I was
experiencing earlier so and with a group
structure it actually oh there we go so
and you see that the first result brings
up this particular one particular masers
conjecture for the MM varieties that
tells you about the closure of a
subgroup of AB um variety and this is
using what you are inputting here it's a
closure or subgroup and trying to see
that the closure is a modifier subgroup
and we want this off the abelian variety
so essentially trying to use the parts
to interpret it and find the closest
match and in comparison you have
something say a Google Scholar where you
see that a lot of the words are
interspersed throughout the text and so
this kind of illustrates the difference
between our search and some general
search in that we are more focused it's
within
a particular theorem and we try to make
the quantifiers and modifiers in the
correct way
just the way that's represented in the
user input right all right just for
completeness sake
here is the result for Microsoft
academic search which is I think he went
worse than googling right I mean this is
really not to ditch on these products I
just think that they fulfill different
purposes and if you want to learn
generally about a particular concepts
definitely go for Wikipedia or Google
Scholar but if you have particular
things like say general fiber is a
product of elliptic curves you see that
here we basically have results that will
try to pull up from these papers what
hopefully what you are asking for great
so and there are various examples
throughout but in the interest of time I
think I'll skip some of these and by
some I mean all of them
right so actually let me try this so so
here is group representations completely
reducible and ideally you are looking
for what are the conditions that will
make your group representation
completely reducible and here are some
of the top results that say in fact and
you find a dimensional representation
completely reduce it all off a compact a
group and you can look at this theorem
right away that's really the essence of
a paper and then of course you can just
browse through and figure out and see
all these other results that are all on
complain with use repetitions of groups
ok great
yeah feel free to talk to me afterwards
about some of these others
and just briefly about the
implementation we as I said we did a lot
of data processing and in particular
extraction of the late tech and of
course that involves dealing with all
the mackerels and doing all the symbols
and so forth to make sure that the
stimuli we extracted actually it's
complete we don't have to rely on all
these tech packages to display our
results and so forth and then we went
through and generated the parses of all
of these theorems that we extracted and
also along with metadata such as say the
author's title and dates and so forth of
publication and we then use the Parsons
theorem to try to find the closest
results as well as a word matching if
supposedly the parsed doesn't somehow
apply and so and this again it's based
on a set of word frequency analysis of
what are the most important words and we
also use synonyms and antonyms and
really the words to figure out well
maybe we have a result not exactly what
you want but something thats related
very slightly differently and so we have
a various search techniques and one of
which is singular value decomposition
that we used for reducing dimensions and
we have the semantic space of around
20,000 words and then we apply just a
usual SVD technique that you might know
from recommender systems down to
certified admissions and that allows us
to search for nearest theorems
well converted to vectors in our case
faster using all building mathematical
functions and so and this is basically
one of the search algorithms and feel
free to talk to me later about some of
the other things we're doing so and
lastly
some question for you is if you were to
have a system like this how would you
want us to expose us to the outside and
how do you think whether to one of our
products a entity store or Wolfram Alpha
or standalone website let us know and if
you have any suggestions let us know as
well and last but not least I would like
to thank my team without whom this would
not be possible but above all Jaime
Michaelson and my coach Alton thank you
very much I talked very briefly about
how we're representing mathematical
theorems in the Wolfram language for the
purposes of entity stores general lookup
so entity store is a function that users
can use to emulate our general data
framework we've curated thousands of
definitions and theorems in pure math
right now focusing on the subjects of
topology and algebra and the
intersection algebraic topology so so
some examples topology concepts these
are things that in a textbook they would
appear as a definition so we got like
the definition of the subspace topology
countable bases etc and there's quite a
lot of these there's theorems there's
general theorems that don't typically
have names like some theorems about how
different bases can have their
topologies related and there's also
named theorems like the TT extension
theorem
there's also algebra definitions these
are mostly about group theory there's
many of those algebra theorems some of
these names should be cleaned up a
little bit but you can see the kind of
coverage that we have
alright now I'll show in a second how we
actually represent the definition
symbolically but there you start with
the logical symbols that we have and/or
implies equivalent subsets etc now we
can already write some mathematical
formulas in Mathematica for example the
statement that the square of any real
number is non-negative this doesn't do
anything on its own but there's
functionality to reduce this and do
computations with it so if this happens
to be a true statement for set theory
that looks bad
shrink this down so you can read these
somewhat in the back we introduce about
50 new symbol well are going to
introduce several of these for
expressing set theories so if you don't
want to write a set you might want to
use set builder notation you can see
what the argument structure that we've
settled on is for that probably cannot
see the very bottom example
so here ever in an example statement
that there are no injections from the
reals into the integers so this is what
it would look like symbolically and then
in traditional form this is how you
might see it in a textbook so what are
the actual properties of these entities
well four concepts we think of these as
functions so the concept is compact you
think of this as operating on some
topological space that returns or
returns whether or not it is compact so
here you see the arguments would be X
the restriction is X must be a
topological space the output is this
complex thing about open covers then
when we want to represent the
application of this concept in a
symbolic description we use the math
head so here we see math of is compact
of Y so this would be the symbolic
statement that Y is a compact
topological space because these are
symbolic we can use make boxes rules and
other things to define formatting to
make transform the symbolic structure
that you see here for say the tube lemma
into something more likely you would see
in a textbook also since they're
symbolic we can just use pattern
matching say look through every theorem
look for the ones that mentioned is
compact concept and you can see quite a
lot of those and these are some other
properties as supported some metadata
type things like references that include
page numbers the references have authors
etc here's another example of a theorem
so this is saying for all X such that X
is a topological space that this
condition holds your material if and
only if your regular and have a signal
locally finite base so this is all being
shown in the summary grid property
there's also this property relations for
certain theorems that this is
essentially an ontological statement
about classes of topological spaces if
you are a mat risible space then you are
also in the class of regular spaces and
the class of signal locally finite
spaces and vice-versa here's an example
of some references that you can pull up
so given any entity you should be able
to find the book that it came from also
what page number they the references are
computable so these typeset citations
are being generated computationally you
can see we have ISBN page count
publisher information author information
these are aligned with people data and
the Wolfram language and here's all the
sources that we have used so far in
curating these concepts and definitions
we also have entities representing
particular examples so we have come we
have definitions theorems and then these
are like example topological spaces for
example here's the real numbers for each
of these will have the elements which
says what the underlying set is which
the underlying set for the reals is the
reals and then you can also see the
symbolic formulation of what the
topology is so the topology is generated
by these open intervals and then all of
these ontological classifications the
reals our Lindelof and they are the
reals do form a manifold with all those
properties you can query things for
example give me a list of topological
spaces at our t1 but are not housed
store right now we don't have many but
this list will be expanded so everyone
can see that at the bottom another thing
we can do with those ontological
relationships between classes of
topological spaces is make sort of a
implication diagram so this is cluttered
let me look at say just the separation
properties let me shrink this down ok so
there's some overlap but you can see
things like is completely normal that
implies normal so this is interactive if
I left click on a node highlights green
highlights everything green that it can
deduce from that another thing that you
can do
is say assume that your t1 well this
will change certain of these properties
will now become equivalent and you can
see that computationally this hi deduce
button so under the condition that your
t1 we know that it's perfectly normal
and is perfectly t4 become equivalent
because of the property relations that
we curated for the various theorems you
can look at cardinality properties if
you have a single point then you are of
course finite and you're not countably
infinite and that is all I have to say
about that ok so I'd like to start by
talking a little bit about what lean is
and what interactive theorem provers are
more generally so an ITP or proofing
assistant is a computer program that's
used to verify that mathematical proofs
are correct
right so no ITP that I know of can
currently do this with sort of natural
language mathematical discourse right
say in the form of a PDF for tech
sources so an ITP defines a language
right that you can use to define
mathematical objects properties
relations and so forth in which you can
state theorems and formulate proofs of
the theorems ITP will then judge whether
the proofs are correct that is does the
proof show that the theorem follows from
the axioms of mathematics and the rules
of logic right so in principle an ITP
verifies the proof down to the axiom so
the precise choice of foundations right
so for instance classical logic and ZFC
set theory does matter right this will
make a difference in terms of what you
can prove but that I think I will ignore
here so to prevent the need to actually
write out the theorems down to the
axioms and ITP also provides typically
a library of definitions and proved
theorems that you can reference right
and it also typically can fill in some
details of a proof which are not
specified explicitly but it can deduce
from context and in some cases it may be
able to automatically generate proofs or
at least parts of proofs right so I
think to the extent that I TPS are known
in the broader mathematical community
it's because they have been used to form
a life formalize and verify some very
complex proofs notably the the
four-color theorem the fight Thompson
odd order theorem and the Kepler
conjecture on sphere packing right I TPS
are also however useful for shorter
proofs as sort of reflected in in the
theorem libraries that are built up
around them right and they have even
begun to be used in courses on logic and
proof taught sort of at the beginning
undergraduate level all right so the the
lien theorem prover specifically is an
open source prover developed at
Microsoft Research much of the
development on the theorem library at
CMU it's implemented in C++ a highly
performant it's based on dependent type
theory specifically the calculus of
inductive constructions and it is
designed to support strong automation
much of that development of sort of
automated theorem proving that is
proving complete theorems without
assistance from a human is in the future
but at least in some code for some
classes of theorems that's already here
okay so I'd like to give you a sense of
what the the lien language looks like so
under the Curie Howard correspondence
the theorem corresponds to a type a
proof of the theorem is then a term of
that type right so so this reduces proof
checking essentially to type checking
right so so given that you may not be
too surprised to see that the language
that lien uses to represent proofs looks
something like Haskell and similar ml
type languages
alright so proofs can also be specified
right now so here I mean in this case
we're actually writing out termed
explicitly right but they can also be
specified with what we call tactic
proofs so you specify a sequence of
tactics each of which contributes to the
construction of the proof term and so
I'd like to give you a sort of a quick
idea of what that looks like so so here
I can step through the proof so so here
this this theorem that I'm looking at is
just it says that if you know P and Q
then you can deduce Q or P right it's
trivial and right the point of lien in
some senses it goes far beyond
propositional logic but just for
illustration purposes you can see here
that what this tells me is I have some
context P and Q are propositions right
and this here after the turnstile symbol
is the goal that's what I want to prove
right and if I apply the intro tactic
right that takes the hypothesis of my
goal and makes it part of the context
the cases tactic now splits that
right so I now have P and Q is separate
hypothesis that I can apply this this
here tells me that well if I want to
prove Q or P I may as well just prove P
right and the Assumption tactic looks to
see whether there are any hypothesis
that matched that right it finds it and
tells me there's no goals left all right
so now I want to talk about sort of the
main event here so the link between
Mathematica and lean here was it was
developed by Rob Lewis and min Chau Wu
min Chow is here today and some of you
may have seen Rob's talk at last year's
conference where he talked about an
earlier version of this link so the link
is bi-directional
you can call lean from the Wolfram
language and vice versa it allows for
arbitrary exchange of information and it
is user extensible so much of that
extension can be done simply by writing
down values in the Wolfram language so
this is all freely available the code is
on github and if you get the the
notebook you'll find links to
instructions for setting up the link
right and I should also mention that the
link is described in far more detail in
a paper by Rob and min Chau they go into
more detail on the internals of the link
give a longer list of applications and
talk something about the the history of
work in this field all right
so so the first direction I want to talk
about is calling the Wolfram language
from within lean so a typical
application here is you create a tactic
which sends an expression
to the Wolfram language for computation
it receives an answer and verifies it
and uses the verified answer in the
construction of a proof so there's in
fact many other ways that you can use
the link so for instance you could
decide to simply trust anything that
Mathematica sends back you do this by
sort of anything you receive from the
Wolfram language you turn into an axiom
but that sort of goes against the point
of a theorem provers generally right so
but but this this scenario that that I
outlined here is particularly useful
when it's easier to verify an answer
than it is to find it right so this is
cases like factoring polynomials
factoring matrices anti-differentiation
solving differential equations and so on
some of these we have actually
implemented so we've created a factor
tactic that does polynomial
factorization lu tech does y lu
decomposition and it's also possible to
develop tactics that are used sort of in
a purely informative role which is to
say we don't actually use the results to
come back from Mathematica in the proof
term so so as an example we have a
sanity check tactic which you just sort
of apply at the beginning of your proof
to try to verify that it is not in fact
false so I'd like to demonstrate some of
these so all right so
just show you here what the definition
of the factor tactic looks like you can
see here that what it does when it
receives an expression is it assembles a
command to send to the Wolfram language
right so does some processing to reflect
in the Wolfram language but ultimately
the work is being done by the factor
function right and then there's some
additional processing to use the lean
simplifier to verify that that it can in
fact prove what it's getting back from
Mathematica so let me show you an
example here so here is a proof that x
squared minus 2x plus 1 is greater than
0 for all real X all right okay so
here's the context X is real we want to
show the polynomial is non-negative when
I apply the factor tactic right it gets
its sends the polynomial to Mathematica
gets the factorization back its verifies
the equation and adds that to the
context as a hypothesis available for me
to use right then the rewrite tactic
uses that to say well to show the
polynomial is greater than 0 it may what
may as well show this this factored form
is and then it calls a lemma that says
in certain contexts squares are always
non-negative right and that completes
the proof all right so here's another
example
maybe this one you can't do in your head
but right so
all right so so that's the factor tactic
let me just show it show what I mean by
the sanity check tactic so here's a
trivial theorem if X is an integer non
negative then it's non-negative all
right so the sanity check tactic here
has nothing to say
go ahead here's another example X is
real suppose we know that sine of X is 0
then let's and suppose we know that
cosine of X is positive can be sure that
X is equal to 0 the sanity check tactic
here complaints right because what it's
done is it's called find instance on the
negation of the theorem and has come up
with a counter example all right so then
if you add an additional hypothesis
right you have a theorem that at least
as far as sanity check can tell is not
false and so you can proceed with the
proof all right all right so now I want
to talk about the the other direction of
the link I so this is what I just spoke
about so calling lean from the Wolfram
language alright so so here the idea is
you send a query from Mathematica to
lean and get a result
typically a proof back ok so the link
defines this function prove using lean
tactic it takes a mathematic expression
right in the name of a tactic which is
then applied all right so this for all
typed function this is sort of a a mild
extension of the for all function in
Mathematica that takes a lean type
alright so this is the proof term sort
of as you might see it in
lean right you can also specify that you
want to get this as a Wolfram language
expression so this is sort of the low
level representation contains all the
data that's used internally by lean and
then in some cases we can do some
transformations that you know throw away
some of the irrelevant information at
least as far as we're concerned to get a
representation that's somewhat more
readable all right so they're so lean
form is is one example of the types of
things that you might want to extend
yourself all right so now I'll just show
a couple of applications right so
Wolfram language provides a very nice
environment for visualizing proofs okay
so the diagram of formula function that
that we put together for this link takes
a statement in propositional logic it
sends it to lean for a proof now
propositional logic is simple enough
that lean can do the proof without any
assistance it translates the proof to a
Wolfram language expression and then
uses the the graph functionality in
Mathematica to generate a natural
deduction diagram all right so and I
will mention that you know this is
currently currently this works for for
statements that can be proved in the
context of into intuitionistic logic a
version for classical logic is in
development okay so right here's an
example of what this does so here's
here's this this theorem we looked at
before if P and Q is true then also Q or
P right so
I'll try to briefly translate what this
says so here's our hypothesis P and Q if
you apply an elimination the and
elimination rule is tells you you know Q
+ or introduction gives you Q or P and
then discharging the hypothesis a you
get the implication alright so here's
another example right so to read this
one it's probably helpful to know that
the way that lien represents not p is as
p implies false alright if you know that
you can follow this proof the same way
okay and here's another example right
all right but so we can go I think far
beyond this you can imagine doing this
not not only for proofs in propositional
logic but for first-order logic
equation logic and and so forth and you
can imagine doing things a lot you know
beyond just graph functionality we have
a lot of dynamic elements you could add
tooltips and other features to be able
to drill down into a particularly large
and complicated proof because you get
sort of a complete specification of the
proof back from from lean you can do
whatever you like you might imagine for
instance converting the proof into
natural language so I'll show one more
example this is more of a minimalist
example rather than trying to return a
complete proof what we do here in the
context of set normalization is simply
try to give you a sketch of the proof by
returning the relevant theorems that
lien used in the proof right so for
instances so here we have a set equality
and lean tells you that what you really
need to know is
the union is commutative and associative
right okay so I think that's all I have
to say about this I did want to make one
sort of final remark and that is that
there are a number of other projects
that we are doing related to theorems
and mathematical knowledge more broadly
that we didn't have time to talk about
at the conference but those include
things like a collection of mathematical
constants additional special functions
coordinate systems and statements that
are equivalent to or otherwise related
to the Riemann hypothesis right so that
we expect to be exposing through the
entity value framework in the near
future so we encourage you to try out
the link right as I say it's freely
available and if you get the slides
you'll be able to find that so now I
think I and Ian and Yi here would all be
happy to take questions
[Applause]
you